nouvelle vidéo de notre série sur la
santé sexuelle aujourd'hui comme promis
on va parler de vaginisme qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est rare comment ça se fait
c'est le ça soigne au bout je propose un
truc regardez la vidéo peut-être si vous
voulez je me dis ça moi je veux pas
je vais répondre à toutes ces questions
que vous vous posez sur le vaginisme et
sûrement à une ou deux que vous vous
posiez pas mais avant de commencer j'ai
un petit truc à vous dire cette vidéo
est sponsorisée par bird bird c'est une
marque de sextoys Premium qui a
plusieurs particularités d'abord elle
est dirigée en majorité par des femmes
et elles ont à cœur de déstigmatiser le
plaisir féminin ensuite leur volonté
c'est de créer des toys à la fois beau
esthétiquement et innovant en termes de
technologie je vous donne un exemple le
Nami Nami c'est un sextoy non pénétratif
et vous allez voir que c'est en lien
avec le thème de la vidéo du jour c'est
un stimulateur clitoridien deux en un si
vous me passez à l'expression deux en un
parce qu'il y a un mode vibration juste
ici et un mode succion juste là il
aspire vous connaissez peut-être il
aspire avec une technologie spéciale qui
permet d'avoir des sensations puissantes
très rapidement enfin c'est ce qu'on m'a
dit moi personnellement je n'ai pas de
clitoris donc mais je connais bien
quelqu'un qui en possédant et elle aime
bien donc mais en vrai on peut aussi
s'en servir sur un pénis si vous voulez
tout savoir et même sur plein d'autres
parties du corps je vous laisse
découvrir pour ça par vous même si vous
avez besoin d'un dessin il y en a dans
le livret mais je peux pas vous montrer
là maintenant sinon je vais me faire
démonétiser voilà donc il y a cinq modes
différents pour chaque fonction il est
en silicone tout et respectueux des
muqueuses il est étanche évidemment et
il est même trois en un parce qu'en plus
il fait veilleuse vous le mettez à
charger sur son socle vous pouvez le
poser sur votre table de chevet et vous
êtes sûr de le retrouver en pleine nuit
en cas de d'insomnie ça fait dormir les
endorphines mais si on préfère dormir
dans le noir complet on peut l'éteindre
voilà Nami c'est leur petit dernier il
est joli vous avez vu il a déjà gagné
quatre prix de design celui là c'est
l'édition jouissance club vous
connaissez sûrement c'est une autrice
qui donne des conseils sexuels dans son
coffret en plus il y a des goodies qui
sont très cool si une amie vous
intéresse ou un autre toy de chez bird
hein moi je force personne je vous offre
10% de réduction avec le CODE DTC il est
valable jusqu'au 12 juillet 2023 et si
vous avez besoin d'une raison
supplémentaire sachez que pour toute
commande passée sur le site bird.co il
plante un arbre je vous ai mis le lien
dans la description de la vidéo
faites-vous plaisir voilà ceci grandi le
vaginisme alors le vaginisme c'est quoi
exactement en fait le vaginisme c'est
une contraction à volontaire des muscles
du périnée le périnée ça vous parle
peut-être c'est pas une chaîne de
montagne c'est pas un fromage non plus
c'est un ensemble de muscles qu'on a au
niveau du petit bassin du bas-ventre si
vous voulez et pourquoi on appelle ça
vaginisme du coup parce que c'est
muscles ils entourent notamment le vagin
et son ouverture du coup quand il se
contracte ils empêchent la pénétration
ou en tout cas il la rende difficile et
douloureuse pénétration de tout de
tampon de doigts de pénis de spéculum
etc un spéculum pas le gâteau le truc
qu'on utilise pour les consultations
gynéco par exemple et le vaginisme c'est
pas une maladie c'est une dysfonction
sexuelle et un terme dont je vous ai
déjà parlé ici qui veut dire en gros ça
se passe pas tout à fait comme je
voudrais et attention ce qui est
douloureux c'est pas tellement la
contraction des muscles c'est plutôt les
tentatives de pénétration plus ou moins
forcées mais c'est rare le vaginisme bah
on sait pas trop à vrai dire on entend
parfois dire que le vaginisme ça
toucherait entre 1 et 3% des personnes
potentiellement concernées c'est à dire
des personnes qui ont un vagin et qui
ont déjà tenté d'introduire quelque
chose dedans
je vous refais pas la liste mais vous
pouvez retourner un petit peu en arrière
si vous voulez mais en même temps le
collège national des gynécologues et
obstétriciens français dit que ça
représenterait 15% des consultations en
sexologie parce que ce qui pousse
souvent à consulter c'est les
répercussions du vaginisme sur la
sexualité mais pas seulement ça peut
aussi être à cause de problème lié aux
douleurs par exemple quand on met un
tampon pendant une consultation gynéco
ça peut être lié à un désir de grossesse
etc et puis bien sûr il y a toutes les
personnes qui font du vaginisme et qui
ne consultent pas forcément donc je
pense qu'on peut dire sans trop se
tromper que c'est beaucoup moins rare
que ce qu'on pense mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe du coup quand on fait du vaginisme
c'est un peu compliqué on a des infos
dessus mais on connaît pas tout si bien
que ça parce que c'est rare bah on a vu
que ça l'était sans doute pas tant que
ça donc c'est sans doute plutôt parce
que les questions de santé sexuelle
féminine sont moins bien étudiées que
les autres mais non mais donc voilà ce
qu'on sait je l'ai déjà dit on sait que
c'est une contraction involontaire des
muscles du périnée donc c'est un réflexe
on sait ce que c'est pas aussi c'est pas
une histoire de vagin trop étroit
[Musique]
qui s'est pas faite correctement dans
notre rapport à la sexualité et la
représentation qu'on s'en fait parfois
c'est lié à l'éducation ou aux croyances
le sexe c'est mal le sexe c'est sale etc
donc tu vois c'est l'inconscient qui
s'imagine que le vagin est trop petit
pour être pénétré voilà donc il y a
plein plein de causes différentes
possibles et il peut même y avoir
plusieurs causes chez la même personne
et c'est définitif la vaginisme non non
pas forcément il y a des trucs à faire
il y a des trucs qui marchent bien il y
a des trucs à pas faire aussi en tout
cas si la personne concernée par le
vaginisme le décide parce qu'elle estime
qu'elle en a envie ou qu'elle en a
besoin elle peut très bien aller voir
quelqu'un gynécologue sage-femme
psychologue kiné etc etc l'important
c'est de trouver quelqu'un qui est
vraiment spécialisé parce que le risque
c'est de tomber sur quelqu'un qui s'y
connaît pas vraiment et qui peut faire
plus de mal que de bien ou sur quelqu'un
qui confond un peu tout parce qu'il peut
y avoir plein de choses qui sont assez
proches voire liés au vaginisme mais qui
sont pas la même chose quand même vu vos
Dini vestibulo Dini disparoni etc etc
c'est un peu compliqué on en Rep aura
une prochaine fois si vous voulez donc
ça soigne le vaginisme oui mais pas
n'importe comment vous avez compris le
vaginisme c'est un réflexe donc c'est
pas un truc volontaire et c'est pas un
truc qu'on contrôle facilement comme ça
non plus la première chose à savoir
c'est que ça ne sert à rien de dire tu
fais un petit effort et puis ça va aller
ou alors c'est dans la tête tout ça en
fait déjà on l'a vu c'est pas le cas le
plus fréquent mais il peut y avoir une
cause physique donc il faut déjà aller
regarder de ce côté là mais en vrai oui
c'est le plus souvent psychologique donc
c'est en partie dans la tête mais une
fois qu'on a dit ça on a rien résolu du
tout culpabiliser les gens avec ce genre
de discours ça crée plus de problèmes
que ça on résout un réflexe ça peut se
déconditionner et pour ça l'idéal c'est
de travailler sur les deux tableaux en
même temps le psychologique en essayant
de comprendre l'origine de tout ça et en
essayant de travailler plus
spécifiquement sur le rapport au corps à
la sexualité à la pénétration etc et le
physique notamment pour apprendre des
techniques qui visent à détendre les
muscles de la zone mais attention l'idée
c'est surtout pas de forcer le truc vous
allez trouver des gens qui vous
proposent des traitements avec avec des
dilatateurs pour distendre les muscles
par exemple ça doit pas se résumer à ça
un vrai traitement ça doit pas juste
rendre la pénétration possible encore
moins en contraignant à la fois le corps
et l'esprit ce qu'il faut c'est qu'au
bout du compte la personne qui est
concernée elle retrouve une sexualité
qui lui convienne et qui soit
satisfaisante pour elle et petit rappel
juste comme ça la sexualité ça se
cantonne pas à la pénétration donc il y
a pas d'obligations à consulter il n'y a
pas de contrainte à s'infliger c'est la
personne concernée qui choisit et qui
fait les choses à son rythme il y a
plein de thérapies possible faut juste
trouver celles qui conviennent voilà DTC
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous bien
je vais répondre à toutes ces questions
que vous posez sur le vaginisme et
peut-être même à une ou deux que vous
posiez même pas
oh mais c'est à chaque fois maintenant
quoi